hey Manmeet Kevin Smith kisum you know
on October 15th on October 17th fathom
events is having screening sneak preview
screenings of Jay and Silent Bob reboot
at a theater near you but what if you
wanted to watch the movie with Jay and
Silent Bob well that's what a reboot
Roadshow comes in ladies and gentlemen
go to reboot Roadshow com to buy tickets
to see Jay and Silent Bob reboot with me
and Jason Mewes right there in the room
we do a Q&A afterwards can be can good
old time we sold out almost all of the
first half of the tour new dates are
coming up man so keep checking and see
if we're gonna come to your neck of the
woods we might sit right next to you
that's right Tweety let's not break up
families and [ __ ] like that we boot
rogues show.com hey man meet Kevin Smith
five years ago it's been five years some
people thought that I put a bullet into
my career by making the movie tusk a
movie about a guy who turns another guy
into a walrus it was one of the most
creatively satisfying experience of my
life one of my favorite movies that I've
ever made it's you know since when it
came out people like what the [ __ ] after
an amazing Toronto Film Festival
screening with standing ovations then
when it came out in the world people
went huh huh
8:24 put it out there it did as good as
jobs they could you know in the movie
did not connect theatrically but has
since found its audience you know we
always figured once it went to Home
Video someone will find it and people
have found it so this is a look back on
how it all happened man Josh rouse was
the rash was with us the whole time
making tusks and he was shooting behind
the scenes stuff Jason Mewes also had a
camera was rolling footage all the time
so Josh was like he-man a five year
anniversary was coming up let's put
together a documentary for tusk us a
[ __ ] yes but do I have to do anything
he's in an intro as a [ __ ] done
so there it is man I lived something
five years ago and there's a footage of
it and now it's being put in together
into one story to show you here man so
this is an innocent time in America
ladies and gentlemen future looks bright
so bright that I'm like [ __ ] it
with walras in it but just long in a
walrus costume wasn't where's there
gonna happen and then the world went to
[ __ ] so I I'm not taking responsibility
for that but you know it's odd
coincidence and timing many of that tusk
is one of my favorite things I ever did
in my life ever came from a podcast as
we all know spawn cast episode 259 the
walrus in the carpenter and it was an
open source experiment like where I was
like let me show the audience how a
movie gets made because they heard me
have the idea on a podcast so I was like
who they were there for the idea stage
now let's take them all the way through
execution perhaps elevation and make
this [ __ ] thing so you know I've
hashtagged on Twitter's like you think
there's a good idea hashtag walrus yes
if you think it's terrible idea walrus
no and I won't pursue it and the next
day a sea of walrus yes one walrus No
and the walrus no said I'm really walrus
yes I'm just saying walrus no to support
the democratic process so at that point
I was like it's time and we went forward
and made this movie man
I don't think I'll ever make a movie
like this again in my life more normally
people start their careers with the
movie like tusks experimental weird edgy
it's fair to say I tried to end my
career with tusks but I couldn't do it
so we made movies after that we're still
making movies but anyway five years ago
ladies and gentleman after having walked
away from film for three years and never
having made a movie what brought me back
to cinema was this strange tale of a man
and his walrus enjoy this documentary on
the making of tusks which I'm gonna call
walrus yes hey Mark
- cuter sparks actually camera action
Michael action parts Cleve knee mister
how well nicely it's Howard
mr. Howard you know when people get in
tail my name is the first time it's much
like a French bedroom farce actually how
would be particularly appropriate but I
prefer a Howard because it's much more
intimate
Howard smashing now with that
unpleasantness out of the way may I
welcome you to Pippy Hill my home it is
pleasure to be here thank you may I
serve you some tea
you may but first can I use your
bathroom
of course right over there okay okay he
says he'd love to try some
JC Muse here man at the production
office of the movie written directed by
Kevin Smith called tusks very excited
I'm not playing the snootch in this one
but I get to be part of the behind the
scenes this is the office we're gonna
step inside we are five days six days
away from shoot day and we're gonna be
getting footage all week but we're gonna
show you what they do in the production
office in a movie set pictures of the
Enclave Enclave which is just awesome
because you look at it here then you go
to the real place and the scene come to
life is amazing
today is the day of the tech Scout now
Tech Scout is where basically every
department head piles in vans look like
that and we drive to every location we
go through the entire script to make
sure everybody's on the same exact page
it's insanely efficient and absolutely
useful I mean you need to and there's
not a movie doesn't have some form of
tech Scout going on you have to it's
smart money does the text cut so you
don't get that on the dango we don't
know we're [ __ ] doing now here's my
only problem the text guy I hate the
text don't you're not supposed to say
that I mean it's why I'm one of the
reasons I'm a poor filmmaker Mike can't
we just pretend to make the movie now
can't we do anything else can we watch
Netflix here and generally they say no
because you're supposed to be working
Wallace oh that's just a beautiful house
sexy just be sexy as we can because the
rest of the time we're in a [ __ ]
closed room two people talking and a
closed Enclave with yes a big fucked-up
walrus I guess that's interesting this
still here we should give them like that
ah there's the house is our big
[Music]
everybody man we are about to go check
out a spot that is dope
you can see the woods over here and it
goes into an old part of the Country
Club
that's off the beaten path and it is
going to be conformed in this movie
magic which is gonna be a zoo it'll be
interesting to see how its confronts
because you cuz it's an empty pool just
water that's brown it looks like someone
put in it peed in it pooed in it
left 4 dead bodies in it be very careful
what we're going to not lean on the
railing at all it's not secure this
place hasn't been open for about a year
so there's a lot of water damage and
stuff so even the stairs are kind of
weak so just watch your footing major
faux pas just happen worst thing that
could ever happen to a dude who's
supposed to be large and a charger in
this case just flat out large has
transpired I was going to step back take
one of these Instagram pictures all the
kids are always doing and [ __ ] like that
felt I was like a 13 year old 14 year
old girl trying to take a picture of our
set didn't look behind me
step through not even a floor is
basically a piece of like foam core like
you put posters on and it's meant to
like bounce some sound nobody was
supposed to be walking over there and
everybody was very clear about like
staying over here and of course I just
didn't look back and I went through man
I was terrified because I didn't know
where I was like I was standing looking
weird going back at the camera and then
all the sudden boom I was looking at
people's heads and all sudden I was
looking at the backs of their knees and
then they were looking down at me I was
looking up with him like help and then
as I tried to pull myself out of it the
rest of it gave and I've plummeted so in
my head I'm like I'm falling but we were
this much off the ground at that point
so I was like aha and then I just
stopped and brushed myself off more
embarrassing than anything else and
every member of that crew all the keys
are just like we supposed to take our
orders from this fat dick can't even
figure out where to walk like this guy
he looks like Winnie the Pooh man it's
embarrassing not a way to begin the
production but I'll win respect back you
will you watch somehow off to pay him
off you guys forget about that it was
you could tell we're in the age of the
cellphone camera because the moment it
happened everyone's camera came out
holy [ __ ] is Instagram material walrus
yes day one official day one of the
picture gonna go out and and bring
Wallace to a funeral kind of the second
scene in the movies were shooting at
first and then ironically were shooting
the first scene in the movie second so
we're off and running first time I've
done this and in three years I'm sure
I'll make a speech about it when we get
there but we're off with the producer
Jenny Shabbat
folks just a real quick welcome I met
somebody I haven't met all the I will
promise I've meet you over course the
next 17 days can't thank you enough for
lending me your craftsmanship I can't do
this alone nor would I if it came to
that I would just kind of give up it's
the belief of everybody here who could
be doing way cooler jobs at other places
normally do way cooler jobs than this
and you could be doing something else on
your time off but you chose to do this
movie that will always mean the world to
me man there was a Philly the
Philadelphia Flyers first year they won
the Stanley Cup in game 6 they walked
into the dressing room and on the
dressing room or the chalkboard very
simple 9 word message and it said win
together today and we will walk together
forever
I feel the same way about this every
[ __ ] moment we win I think the movie
will catch on when we're done I think
people at least talk about it
and then we'll always have this common
bond together so thank all of you from
the bottom of my heart I hope to meet
all of you shake hands get your names
and [ __ ] because you're making my dream
come true today I now turn everything
back over to our amazing first day deep
thanks for being here on day one of dusk
[Music]
nonsense
[ __ ] Burt Reynolds and Smokey and the
Bandit is somebody worn a mustache that
proudly you got it right I don't think
that was a problem I think every guy
they were just like we thought we were
going in a different direction with this
black man who knows me more of this
jersey walls like somebody came over and
was just like your little buddies going
on my last nerve
that's me a [ __ ] question oh sorry
sorry hotel you were about to give a
speech so us what you in charge these
welcome to Wohlers if that's what you in
charge of these so that you could just
take charge use like so sorry but when
you clean will happen hey what should we
do it's true it's true I was out
directing I you know we just shot our
first shot on toss we got two first two
cameras and it was so brilliant we're
moving on we're on to our second setup
well if technically a third set up for
there are two setups and then so we're
off and running man long crushed it he
gets to lead left convincing on camera
that's all we needed really in that shot
and and also beautiful car pulling up
shot looking like a Manitoba countryside
even though technically we're really in
North Carolina so off to a wonderful
story
it's movie magic and see that's why I
didn't have questions cuz I knew he'd
blow it out to water if it's [ __ ]
movie magic why are you makin excuses
nobody wants to hear about your fuck-ups
anymore they just wanna hear about the
glory of tusk it's true wall chess
[Music]
I would like to know what this sweet
young smooth item is where to come from
what it is and why do you have it
this is a walrus that I was given as a
birthday gift I'm a good lady wife
Jennifer this birthday was very easy to
shop for me because I was in the throws
of tusks I just finished a script and I
was pushing it toward production so
everything I got was kind of walrus
themed and this was one of them
everywhere we go walrus yes and whatnot
so he's the mascot that sits here at the
station but the other mascot it's right
here and once he puts this on go ahead
that's not how you put you've got put
the rubber band around you've it all the
way around I was it put it around my
ears
[Music]
see man so when this walrus isn't around
this walrus is around this is the mascot
the official mascot this is the backup
mascot for when like the real mascot is
sick but don't worry folks stuffed
animals never get sick so we just tell
him he's the backup mascot heir and a
spare that's not even a walrus noise
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're not nice we're optimistic right
and we're tolerant and we're hung like
moose get out of here
even the ladies okay back to business
then listen man big day for us here when
I say big I mean tall [ __ ] a little
fat look not at all there's no pounds
come on the hell out but it's all height
nineteen with my go like when I was a
kid my mom would be like oh yeah you're
heavy but you're big-boned
you're tall bone look at this this is
Balthazar look it's a it's a [ __ ] for
the movie yeah slap him he likes to be
yeah right there I don't I'm not gonna
do anything like that my belly is sacred
this is Harley Harley as the store of
the store the star of course of Epic
Meal Time now how's Harley wind up in
this picture funny you should ask
out of the mouths of babes another
vermin sometimes comes wisdom
this [ __ ] right here we're
sitting there gone who will play the
border guard border agent his first
character almost that we meet at the
head of the movie with Justin's
character Wallace so we're like we know
some Canadians we're like let's get a
Canadian stuff we were going through the
list some [ __ ] was very obvious mr.
Jason Mewes man jumps into the fray it
was him look at that and he was just
like dude what about that dude from Epic
Meal Time you like that guy said
Harley's a [ __ ] giant nice funny I
like that guy
I didn't not anymore but Superman
Superman odd [ __ ] now here's the
beautiful thing about this cat man you
were what a teacher yeah I was a high
school teacher for two years what
happened how did you get out of the I
started getting drunk on the internet
and people liked it and so I was like
[ __ ] the kids sorry
is that beautiful
Oh
it's so beautiful
[Music]
this is something that you can't miss it
is this this is like a this is almost a
portrait I wish I was a painter excited
paint this look at that view right there
man you got the crane which is up there
I don't know that's a 40 20 30 40 foot
crane looking over we got the fire which
is is you know that's a man-made fire
which all fires man-made but sorry it is
fire that is make pretend then we got a
walrus make the Pend then we got the
people you got the camera we got the
smoke the fog I mean when this thing is
going it's gonna look dope cause it'll
be fog doesn't be fire and there's gonna
be a bro a dude eating fresh meat I am
talking to two ninjas as I say but this
seam right here there's some business
going on and I can't do it justice so
I'm gonna hand the mic over to my left
and if you don't mind giving your name
say what you do as job and all that and
then you could pass it to her and you
guys tell us what's what and I'm John
Kretchmer production designer on Kevin
Smith's film tusks this is Skylar
Crimson and she's the the sculptor of
this wonderful and art farmer
coordinator but this weekend she's the
sculptor of this wonderful piece of
walrus flesh in the background and a
Skylar how do we put this together
there's an exercise ball inside and many
trash cans and laundry baskets a lot of
zip ties and beer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
end of day one as you can see it's night
and that's when days end we had a split
we started at 10 o'clock we're ending on
time at 10 o'clock
tremendous looking footage James lakhs
and crushing it just movie looks classy
way classier than a Wohlers picture has
any right to look my boy Matt who's an
office PA we threw him into the role of
the young Michael parks and he boy he
looks the part man and he did great kids
never acted before when we had my camera
all day all night rather in the cold he
was soaking wet in the last shot
climbin across his butt on the rocks on
his belly and [ __ ] didn't a phenomenal
job man that kind of passion enthusiasm
or willingness to do [ __ ] that most
others wouldn't
that's what elevates your your dopey
walrus movie into something even more
classy so as we wrap day one excellent
job by the cast and crew across the
boards man and hopefully it's all like
this
[Music]
welcome back to walrus yes day two of
tusks production man and as you can see
this is the day as so elegantly written
across this box I can't make that out
because it looks like a child drowning
in a lake
unguarded as writing it has her final
words this trip down drowning child is a
girl look how [ __ ] poor this
penmanship is you look at I told them
one simple thing yeah he picked up the
computer he packed it with the avidin
stuff like that and then we burn into
mom said just write on a tusk editorial
that says if you can read a tusk
editorial look at this uncertainty look
he went back over it and it was just
like it should be thicker but then
wouldn't commit to thickening any other
letter a handwriting analysis would have
a field day with this everyone else is
just like who wrote that man there's is
that is somebody just learning
penmanship writing that is that a
three-year-olds attempt at letters no
man that's mr. Jason Mewes CSI team
would totally be able to figure out the
heartbeat it wouldn't have to do any
weird zooms or flashbacks they'd look at
it and be like this chicken scratch
Jason Mewes anyway day two begins first
day with Michael parks man we're already
running late so
[Music]
telling your handbill intrigued me okay
okay I'm really good oh all right guys
I'm whispering because and I don't know
if you could tell them what's Bretting
I'm on the mic but this is gonna be the
first scene with Michael Park so we're
about the street Michael parks first
scene they're rehearsing it's awesome
we're gonna take a little look he
looky-loo through the monitor because
the sets very small we don't want to get
in anyone's face but we're gonna get to
see a little bit of rehearsal action
let's do that
[Music]
you can absolutely but first
okay well cute is for Chinese babies mr.
Bryton
but my walrus companion was beautiful I
have never known such a fulfilling
friendship with anyone would you it'll
be all right and we alright mister
[Music]
material and this is the [ __ ] movie
so thank you man we got there we got
there in a big way we won today stars on
Michael parks crushed today but Justin
came in there and just absolutely
[ __ ] crushed parks [ __ ] crush we
have magic in this sequence right here
this is the movie because this gets
everybody and then even just sitting
there watching him talk I was drawn in
so I'm delighted there was a minute
there where it looked like we weren't
gonna make our day and we [ __ ] made
our day as well
James Laxton set us up with so many nice
shots we were able to hit it all and
make everything and not have to put
anything on to tomorrow so very very
impressive day this is day 3 you could
tell we're in the thick of it because
I'm wearing a hat what does that means
that my director hat no it means I
didn't [ __ ] shower this morning
because I was editing got the Edit up
and running and it's no longer an avid
and on a giant desk in one place it is
on a [ __ ] laptop we're in the future
kids I'm like walking around at it I was
editing on the [ __ ]
it was amazing amazing but I lost track
of time as a [ __ ] I didn't get a chance
of shower so we're rushing right now off
to work it's like riding a bike don't
real last thing was it like riding a
bike like it took a sec but then you're
like oh they will oh it was like
masturbating
that's how second nature it was wasn't
even like riding a bike riding bikes our
Morgan an avid is like easy as pie it's
like jerking off there's a net there's a
commercial for avid avid we're like
jerking off
[Music]
[Music]
I see you have an eye for the infant
been here this is they got walrus spine
no it's more like a walrus [ __ ] shut up
dirty boy harder
[Music]
we're heading into day for man we had an
amazing day three yesterday I turned our
deep P James Laxton and I says to our DP
I says on about you buzz best thing I
ever done film he loved it yesterday it
was it was a pleasure man like people
were coming up to me and just people on
the crew just talking about like oh my
god I was amazing Justin was like I was
on the watch and he was he got lost man
lost in parks storytelling parks brought
the pulp parks yesterday so now we head
into day for four more full parts we
still Justin into the walrus costume I
feel like if when you look up when you
look on the monitors it's awesome
because it's almost to get night and go
home put it on and he could read any
book and you would sit there and watch
and sit and watch him I told him yes
tears like dude leave my phone message
that's how beautiful is voices replace
this Yoda phone message I bought online
with your own dulcet tones that's how
impressive he is would you want him to
view his voice but in the order where
he's like well yo leave a message oh
that's Yoda if there are even parts all
right yes and we have to be like do or
do now
yes probably near that he's not anyway
back to work day for walrus yes figure
that up I'm gonna get it thank you
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the exact guarantee
[Music]
man is such a savage animal mr. Bryton
better to be a walrus
better to be you know what that is you
know what that is just in case someone
doesn't know and they think that's fangs
I mean it's clear to us because we're on
the set but if you saw that driving down
the road you might think that's fangs
for a vampire but no this ain't no
vampire movie baby this is a walrus
movie and this is tusks and this is what
I love man this is when you get a cool
crew I mean they get into it you get
they make up shirts they make stickers
and jackets and bags and altars and
stuff some people put foot tusks on
their car on the bumper dude so I don't
know we came in this morning we saw that
it's so lovely all right man Jaime's
here again with bars yes and this is day
five and the end of week one if you will
it's our first week if you will yes so
I'm excited I want to know what you
think sir we've come to an end of a very
productive week got great stuff I shot
some of the best footage for anything
ever shot in my life during this week so
it's productive man got me a homeland
hat oh look at that man I've been rats
on the crew and whatnot so I've become
North Carolina and I am Charlotte I'm
the CEO tea watch is here to say why all
right now do you think with the hat that
it makes you feel like you would want to
maybe direct or be on the set of
homeland happen Eli make a [ __ ] kid
and play reference a house-party
reference you don't even jump in there
you're all like homeland and serious TV
sorrows in all businessman is it makes
me nervous I get all serious cause it's
our end of day one week one one but wait
what was your kid and play reference
let's do it again
oh [ __ ] yeah we can't bring it back I'm
sorry just know day five walrus yes yeah
we're at lunch people were wrapped with
two hours of spare I know it's pretty
cool I'm not so hard to do that's great
do they give you a I know it's her yeah
all right pretend I'm gonna do all this
little more stern-looking
[Music]
to make a move slow sure sir so I wanted
to know how was that so here we gotta go
we're gonna get a real quick come to
harass mr. Zack before he leaves how it
was being Hemingway he looks the part
right now
not the outfit but we got the outfit
earlier but now we get to see the face
and ask how it was my friend my face
feels naked it does I would imagine
having a beard I don't ever grow one but
I would imagine having something warm on
your face for weeks and weeks sometimes
months and then it disappears feels
naked although I can play a cop or a
fireman real easy right now I like it I
like how this looks it's sexy but that's
it do you go home now or are you gonna
fly out tomorrow he flies home already
he comes and he bangs it out he does
like one take each cuz that's how he
rolls thank you sir for being part of
walrus yes and finally Muse gets to
harass you thank you for having me yes
week one went phenomenally everybody you
know it's of course you're supposed to
say everyone's pulled together and do a
great job but like literally every both
public together and did a great job
phenomenal cast and crew man across the
board it's like better work than a movie
of this size deserves but that just
shows you like people love the idea
people love the story you know I'm sure
like everyone likes getting paid and
[ __ ] but they're a bunch of different
jobs [ __ ] would be doing other
movies but they're here cuz they all
everyone just wants to see if it'll work
and it's lovely when you watch everybody
doing like a hundred and ten two hundred
percent I know that's mathematically
impossible but they're doing it just
because they love the story because they
love the idea of like yeah hell yeah
this will be fun so I you know it's been
a great first week man the footage looks
fantastic we were making days left and
right that our sick days man shot nine
pages dialogue one day is more than I
ever shot in my [ __ ] life so great
first week and to me honestly like this
was the hardest week I know we got a
week coming up with big rubber suits and
[ __ ] and logistical nightmares but this
was the big chunk particularly all this
study stuff is just pages and pages
dialogue and then figure and
how to make it look interesting enough
where we have four different sides of
the conversation that you know present
it in such a way where it's not just two
dudes talking to each other even though
that's what it is
so I was like nervous about this week
but after this week I'm kind of over my
hump everything else even the rubber
suits of it all can be figured out like
this was the toughest nut to crack and
we cracked it hard in our mouths and it
ran down our cheeks yes Oh are there
little dirty at the end for it this is
I've seen what I've seen it's been
visually exotic and stimulating and the
acting they're the the worker
organization's finest film critics I'm
seriously though I wish I could word it
better you're right I get a little
nervous when I'm around him for some
reason when you want it made me getting
a boner I'll just say back to effective
noises yes I got a straight-up boner
watching the two acting that visually
the fireplace the the way it looks the
movements everything I saw was awesome I
saw you chuckling behind the camera and
and to see that when that happens I know
it's good even from afar because I've
been on a few movie sets with this man
so I say it went well too insanely well
very like way better than we imagined it
would it's it's been a great week for
walrus yes thank you
[Music]
[Music]
first so you said you'll and look and
then as you've race away
I'll give it an off of an off-camera Wow
this that's what's driving you up as I'm
running in that direction a series here
on walrus and I'm whispering because
there's a crowd around me and this is
the first day with home Genesis and
Haley but why were whispers cuz there's
a hot set the other room look at the
monitor looked at the monitor look at an
edge say we're doing some action shot is
like the first action II shot of the
movie where people run for the last week
people have been walking into room
sitting down talking to each other and
Liz shot my boogers are running man ever
see some desperation and whatnot and
it's also our first shot of week not a
first run week to what a first shot with
Genesis and Haley their first day of
week two so it's exciting right after
this gotta [ __ ] foot still gonna have
an ice bucket man they get to see the
room this is like the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre moment when they fall into the
only room [ __ ] so butter you know a
walrus movie version of that so it's
happening man
Heaney got weapons yeah there's guns he
was very excited as soon as they they
were like oh you know cold weapons on
set he was like mmm good good good
and so he came over and then like a
jackass he was like corner lows and I
got yelled that I did Gail that's the
one number one rule never on the set
just I complained you never say fire
fire same thing same plant you can't say
bombs really oh yeah you can't say pong
can't say Hitler what if you were saying
in an airport if what if you were
singing Cherry Bomb aloud
sorry let's go there it could greetings
are being taken away one by one now we
can't even say cherry bomb on an
airplane and even on a make-believe
place like this you can't say quarter
load I should say full load but anyway
that's wall obsessed with day one of
week two with the new cast new peeps new
attitudes let me back this is our bar
manly the most
this is my come here yes the camera team
sitting in they're gonna be stars movie
stars hey hey
you hot little mama I'm in [ __ ]
Winnipeg in a bar called bar H name is
pronounced bar
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I think cake right everyone you can't
really see me you can hear me but you
can see the game here we're about to
play we're gonna learn the rule book
here we go let's do this
the board game
we're playing walking dead here with
génesis rodríguez is the best big Walker
is ribery yes is that Irish we're
playing The Walking Dead her and I it's
her first day
yeah enjoying it so far oh yeah I'm
having a blast
she got to run through that awesome
study and then come out here and hang
out with boring old me playing walking
dead not a bad day but I am winning so
far so I know he's kicking my ass when
you're like that was your first line oh
yeah the accents and the BM and the BM
yes
okay now stick with me here I don't mean
to be indelicate but could there be some
sort of sexual angle alright Jason Mewes
here with a test for walrus yes I'm
about to talk to his scholar and a
gentleman someone that I is dear to my
heart man and he is here in North
Carolina and he's gonna give us his name
and tell us what he's doing here hey
Ralph Garman here you may know some of
you may know me as the co-host of
Hollywood babble-on
but right now I'm just another lowly
actor on the set of tusks playing a
Canadian detective in Winnipeg Manitoba
don't you know and here for the day
could have some fun with the boys and
then [ __ ] on back to Dollywood and you
look the part you know what I would like
to see is what I really like honestly I
want to get one eventually I'm gonna see
if I get by whenever is I'd love to
change with the
yeah so hopefully they have one for him
and maybe I could steal it I might keep
it as a souvenir
hey that leg bit it sure puts the BM in
the PM's coffee but the leg bit that's
the double-double son Sucre that's the
real kick in that Tim bit see it's the
real news on the Moo see that's the real
to fry stick Ernie that's really a slap
shot enough five holy that's something
[Music]
another night another day done what do
you got to say this is the end of day
six of the production we had génesis
rodríguez went on camera for first time
today as did Haley Joel Osment
Ralph Garman was on camera today he
worked and rapped today but Haley in
Genesis they're just getting started man
and we shot some an action beat with him
first and we got to do dialogue later on
it was a good day we bought ourselves a
15th day of production so we were able
to kind of ease up on the schedule a
little bit and today was nice like we
didn't run up to the finish line we
didn't have to lose anything it was just
a good day so lots of great stuff we
shot and and we're getting into the
other parts of the movie now I'm sorry
I'm [ __ ] baked we're getting into
other parts of the movie now not just
you know people talking to each other
for the whole first week of production
like the movie was an old man and a dude
and a mustache talking to each other so
today suddenly there was a girl and then
there were guns and then there was
action and then there's a police and
then there was a reference to deal
appoint who we don't even shoot out here
like suddenly I remembered oh yeah
there's all this other [ __ ] going on in
the movie you know we didn't even get to
the walrus suits yet so this movie's
packed man packed this was yet another
good day wash ass day six
a man Kevin Smith
JC Muse walrus yes running a little late
this morning when I say a little I mean
call time is about ten minutes ago but
we have an exceptional crew DP James
Laxton first ID ELISA Frederick's they
all know what they need to do is so
they're preparing for the first shot
which involves Genesis and Haley however
I used this extra time this morning to
center and then as I was centering I
said this podcast scene should be better
the one that we're shooting today so I
sat down I said rewrote the entire
podcast scene way way better way more
fun and it involves foosball yeah that's
right man a little piece of you skew
history we used to play foosball we
still play foosball but we just play
foosball the wreck together man so now I
saw a table on set yesterday I was like
they got a [ __ ] foosball table
movements in the scenes they're gonna
sit there and chitchat over the foosball
table second half of the scene that's
mostly what we're doing today walrus yes
day seven clear was awesome
that was amazing I know where you were
going with that video but I'm glad you
did it was embarrassing but [ __ ] those
[ __ ] funny
[Music]
I would request
James rips one camera here completes all
right now anyway yeah I'm get this guy
though that didn't matter
yeah
[Music]
it's clear that guys spent five days in
Cramerton where you staying no that's
fine but we just gotta get you you're so
close you're leaving here and going home
right yeah that's right North Carolina's
lovely of course but you are within
spitting distance of Manhattan at least
be able to go back to be like and then I
saw New York yes this guy right here is
responsible for this guy right here man
this is crisp Parkinson Parkinson Chris
comes from a faraway land called writes
in Brighton the UK the the origin of
tusk is found in an online ad from a
website called Gumtree UK where you can
look for living arrangements and and we
talked about it on SModcast it captured
my imagination captured a lot of
people's imagine they should travel all
over the internet meme doubt wound up on
the news and stuff like that and it was
a story about a man who was offering a
room free room to a lodger who all they
had to do in return was once a day for
about an hour
dress up like a walrus and you couldn't
speak and you could only make noises
like a walrus and he'd whip you fish and
crabs and stuff so you know this bent my
mind and we were having a good time
talking about it's my caste and that's
we were talking about it we started
shaping it into a horror movie going
like this so our movie would get that
guy there as you could turn you into the
human walrus so all of that of tusk
everything we're doing out war was just
all predicated on that Gumtree add that
Gumtree dot uk' add with a man was
soliciting for a lodger
what we found out was it was a hoax it
wasn't real at all it was made up by
this little gremlin right here hello I
am looking for a loader in my house I've
had a long and interesting life and have
now chosen Brighton as a location for my
retirement
among the many things I've done in my
life is to spend three years alone on
some Lawrence Island these were perhaps
the most intense and fascinating years
of my life and I was kept in
companionship with the walrus whom I
named Gregory this is a position I'm
prepared to offer for free eg no rent
payable on the fulfillment of some
conditions I have over the past few
months been constructing a realistic
walrus costume it's sure it was the it
was just a great pole because it's so
adorable the walrus is adorable and it's
like it's just so offbeat enough where
you're like [ __ ] that ad must be real
and and so we were like dude without you
there there's no flick you need to put
that ad and in order for it to one day
grow into this ridiculous film so we
said come on in just like in the movie
business we're like come on producer I'm
the movie so they're how amazing is that
man a world away guys just like I know
ha ha ha and a world away of fat guys
like walrus man boom heart
[Music]
Robert Kurtzman and creature effects
designer on the film this is the walrus
stuff with building all the walrus suit
cool well right now right now we're just
going through and taking our time
popping our stitch areas getting them a
little more detail we're all just
working on getting this stuff ready for
next week and get ready to put Justin
and the stunt performers and Michael
into these suits and do their makeups
they have prosthetics that go over this
and attach to these suits so is this the
first time you've made a walrus suit
whatever been asked to make Kevin Smith
walrus yesterday where's my little buddy
gone man he's not here I'm doing it solo
doesn't matter I don't need a man could
always been silent Bob and more silent
bob instead of the other dude anyway day
eight kids hump day middle of the chute
man we've got a 15 day shoot here was 14
we made it 15 do stunts on the 15th day
so at lunch today we will officially be
at the halfway point of tusks isn't that
crazy six months ago sitting around
goofing about of this on the podcast now
we're almost done shooting that footage
looks amazing it was cutting last night
I rewrote some scenes today for the
bedroom scenes today is very delicate
underwear seeing young lady in her
underwear génesis rodríguez parading
around and about two inches of clothing
so I told her put on more clothes this
is my world women wear pajamas but she
got one of them body you could show off
so she happened to show it off I was
thin I'd be [ __ ] showing my body else
to it I'd be jerking off in public votes
then and then the event today the very
intimate portions of tusks crane stuff
set up but it is a closed set today so
we can't bring the camera we're
literally a foot away from the car you
might not care but I want to say that
because
when there's a closed set it means
closed set not only you're not allowed
to hang out we can have cameras here
except for the actual camera that is
shooting so that will probably probably
won't get a lot of stuff today on day
Kevin I think mentioned it already
Dave Age day a baby a man Kevin Smith
JC Muse walrus yes day nine yesterday
was magic
kids we shot Genesis Rodriguez and her
scene with Justin and Bette their
characters Allie and Wallace but then we
shot some [ __ ] at night it was just
magical man we just had her stare down a
barrel the camera and just slowly zoom
in at her as she did this monologue she
start crying [ __ ] dope so today we go
we do a lot outside work of Teddy and
Ali running through the woods to get to
the how house and then at the mid white
mark we do the big dinner scene where
how and Wallace sit down and kind of
start get the feeling what's going on
like Wallace realizes he's [ __ ] so
this is going to be creep is really
awesome shot I heard them the camera
team talking about how they're gonna
shoot it and I it sounds awesome and you
giving them you know direction and stuff
yeah and I'm gonna be excited so I'm
excited for today we're gonna check it
out and we'll see you later
[Music]
[Music]
a man kevin smith walrus yes we're
shooting outside Pippy Hillman this is
where the Howard Hal character lives
Michael parks character in this sequence
justin pulls up to the gate sees it
heads up the long driveway and then most
of the movie takes place here at least
in the flick with the interiors we shot
down the street but in any event this is
our neighborhood this is our world and
up top here is the hill this is really
weird what's your name fuzzy fuzzy here
man lives down the street yeah three
houses down three houses down and we
were just chatting out before and fuzzy
listens to the podcast so I was like oh
if you listen to SModcast this is
episode this is a walrus and the
carpenter'
and he's like I heard that episode and
then what was the other one I heard you
on get old talk about scouting locations
on HDL of a babylon talked about picking
charlotte and then also falling through
the set we need a poo incident yeah
talked about falling through the set so
how wild is that man that we're actually
shooting on a street and and only six
months ago it was kind of born on the
podcast nice neighborhood have we been
loud and shitty no it's awesome you can
do whatever you want you could drive the
car through my house if you want
it's almost got it but to me it's just
so wild that like you live downstream
you're like oh I know that I know that
show and you've now kind of seen every
piece of like evolution up to and
including like shooting right down so
where are you which how far down a third
house down on the right here right by
the spotlight is so [ __ ] wild when you
first came in my friend saw you at
Target and he took a picture out front
and I was like wow this is so cool Kevin
Smith's shooting the movie in our
backyard Charlotte and it comes you're
pretty much screwed in my backyard but
actually my front yard so [ __ ] fuzzy
man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
this is day 10 of the show normally we
jump at you as we're heading into the
day today I'm coming at you as we close
as we close the day Jason Mewes went out
of town or go to a horror convention and
stuff so I was on my own all day long no
wingman no no Jay to my salad Bob it was
weird but great day a lot of exterior
stuff we were worried there was a 60%
chance of rain warning and we got a
little rain but it didn't [ __ ] us
actually worked out pretty nicely big
crane shots a lot outside work was
supposed to be kind of freezing tonight
but we got away look it's not I could
literally not wear a coat if I wanted to
so we got lucky there so a lot of our
night exterior stuff was that's what we
were doing all day long and it turned
out really well and this is the end of
Pippy hill for us the where Michael
parks is character lives we don't come
back here ever anymore in the shoot
Justin's mustache I was a wrap on
Justin's mustache today because he now
goes into the makeup and they take the
mustache off so I could put prosthetics
on so we're gonna at the end of week two
date day 10 is day 9 day 10 is the end
of week 2 we've officially shot for two
weeks so far I couldn't be happier man
but Ann's down best movie I ever made
best crew ever worked with like it's
getting amazing amazing stuff and the
movie looks fantastic and it's weird and
[ __ ] up and I don't know it's cool I
was telling these cats oh so good this
movie's a guy made clerks really would
have loved man it scary very blue velvet
ish and stuff so day 10 as we close our
week to nothing but good right here in
Kramer to North Carolina man all guy
recommend wholeheartedly if we're gonna
make a movie come here to North Carolina
these cats are great but once again
productive week happy week and we're
inching ever closer to the Enclave next
week is all the walrus Enclave and
working with the rubber suits which is
so weird because we haven't touched that
part of the movie really at
we've been doing people talking to each
other and everything leading up to the
suits so now for the last week it's all
suits all pool all water all Enclave and
hopefully Michael does not fall into the
pool that's my nightmare I wake up every
night going like he fell in the pool
like as long we can get through a week
without losing parks into the pool or
taking a header or slipping because you
know I felt through the floor at the set
when they were still building I'll be a
happy camper man I'd be a load off at
that point so barring that one more week
here in North Carolina of tusk and then
we wrap we have three days left to do in
Los Angeles in December but the chunk of
the movie men 90 percent of the movie
will be shot at this point it's wild
anyway I say Wallace yes
[Music]
happens to be married to Jason Mewes
don't hold it against your Jordan or a
[Applause]
man Kevin Smith Jason Mewes walrus yes
behind us equipment film equipment don't
know what it is it might be a camera I
think it is a maybe might be one of them
digital cameras I'm pretty sure there's
a red lady's jump in any event as you
see we're on a set we're on the set this
is day 11 of the movie two to ones close
together not like though that's more of
a be it's the first day we work with
makeup of week three day one a week
three and also the first day there's a
lot of math to this one man or making
them figure out allows you three times
one is four is sit nine one one and one
and one is three got to be good not we
don't want to pay toast royal teas in
any event this is the the beginning of
the last week and all the most
complicated stuff now kicks in man
because it's not just people sitting
there talking to each other it's people
sitting there talking to each other and
sometimes they're in makeup and
sometimes they're in big suits so it's
uh this is this is hell week man but
thank God we got a heavenly crew so it's
never hell here in Charlotte North
Carolina or more specifically right here
in the heart of Cramerton where we've
made our movie tusks today we're gonna
shoot if you look to the left the sad
little walrus hut where the movie kind
of concludes spoilers but it's it's it's
it's a sequence that we even talked
about on the podcast when when tusk was
being born so it's weird it's weird to
be here six months after that
conversation to sit down and be like oh
this is what it would look like and and
the Kretchmer and his production team
production design team put together just
the saddest little wayward animal zoo on
the planet so here we go man
week three what you got a question yeah
just as today I know this is week
restart here for the shoot today do we
then go over to the enclaves
the first day that you see the Enclave I
will do that as a separate thing for
peace so I will just shut up now he took
the reins he was the psyche now I will
be the one in charge because I have
something valid to say and he got shut
down he was like oh shut up
no worn leader
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how's your movie today they found some
clubs and some balls
have you been in in here yet yeah
awesome right oh you got balls now
[Music]
so today's your last day yes for a
little while come back in LA so Li in
him but you had a blast oh yeah yeah
this is this is a great it's a great
pace and Kevin is a really good guy to
work for and and yeah just get to get to
spend my time with Justin Genesis yeah
they were great yeah I mean I was we
were talking about today like everyone
seemed to get along great right away you
know so way back it was started all this
from the moment sat down talked about a
story about The Walrus and the lodger
on SModcast there is always I don't know
I think I used it on the podcast I refer
to as walrus Enclave don't even know
it's a correct term for it but it's
become the term this is the enclave set
now I haven't seen I've seen pictures
I've seen designs never been on the set
man I want to wait until it was time you
have to compartmentalize stuff when
you're directing and I'm like this don't
exist till the third week well its third
week and it's time for the Enclave to
exist and this is magical because it's
starting a conversation and it was a put
in print and it was an idea at one point
we had a picture of something that could
have been it but then Kretchmer John
Kretschmer like designed like some
you've never seen before something very
singular something so [ __ ] chilling
and spooky and weird and people remember
it and it's weird because we haven't
shot that part of the movie at all yet
we live here all week and live in that
Enclave but up until now it's all been
done you know the mansion set and stuff
like that so this is where we spend a
great deal and moving out we get to see
it this is what we
produce kids oh my god that's where I
felt something this is amazing this is
just awesome
I haven't seen the projection man that
looks right you look at this I wish this
is where our smart Co headquarters was
right right now that's great in Miami
should this is the set that we spend so
much of the movie on and I have in terms
of what people will remember about the
movie Justin the what and the walrus
eating stuff were the first things they
talked about this is the room where all
of that happens is where the rules and
Kurtzman showed us footage of the suit
in the pool and how the tail can move
and stuff it's crazy man I was a little
nervous going into this week because
dealing with the variables of costumes
and [ __ ] and dealing with this we
haven't been here but I got no fears
whatsoever man very smart individuals
were working on stuff like I saw the
footage of Justin moving like super boom
boom
like running with as if a walrus can run
but on his belly so [ __ ] up so I don't
know this is this right here is the
throne room of [ __ ] up for this whole
movie so it wins I wish every shot we
could think of more tissues and it is in
yeah yeah like a three shot right
pow pow pow die before is over we'll put
follow in it if you want oh let's do
three fours so we put squibs in both
sides of the door and wired them in
together and they'll come out in the
corner
and we'll put it on a remote and we'll
hit them one two three and the third one
should break the latch so they can keep
the door up you sort of said look in
here and you can sort of see how we
drill them out and and we just want to
get and leaving enough wood that it
don't leave just a perfect hole
[Applause]
[Music]
in Spanish now say that's a rap in North
Carolina
I hate Jamie's not really a lover in
Spanish Piero's khan kluay con la
película tasks in north carolina a
Dorothy hombre oh yeah oh yeah
[Music]
should be used for equipment everyone
else just start using the stairs start
directing that way I'm gonna maybe shut
the door
what should we not do do exactly we just
did don't come up that ramp hello
everyone GC Muse here Kevin Smith on
walrus yes
day 12 Tuesday last week at the Enclave
I'm very excited what do you have to say
sir so today is the reveal of the walrus
in the movie yesterday we just shot a
shot of the walrus but today what we're
doing right now is the first time what's
up Kurtzman look at grab that look at
that genius genius at work flip the
camera back that's like catching Picasso
on his way to a [ __ ] cafe or [ __ ]
Shakespeare on his way to patronizing
[ __ ] or hookers as they said back in
the day in any event and probably do a
snap zoom out very 70s influenced
picture we got going on so right now
we're composing for that for Michael not
for not for the verbal shop but for
everything that leads up to it so
Michaels crossing the bridge and he's
reciting Lewis Carroll and then he comes
to arrest closes the bridge the
drawbridge which keeps tusk captive and
then he sits on the railing or leans on
the railing and has a conversation with
tusk and there's where he's like
walruses never cry and then we snap zoom
out on we should go on on justin's face
for the first time and you see him in
the makeup hahahaha we [ __ ] snap out
he's like ha ha
so it's gonna be [ __ ] it's gonna be
goofy and weird and evil I'm excited
yeah I'm excited uh I'm a little tired a
little Bakey this morning sorry but you
got to be on the picture like this I
mean rubber walrus suits everywhere why
not be paid
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now isn't this peaceful to the soul this
is just a poor facsimile of that magical
Enclave when we met we became such good
friends
until that
rifle day
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what I'd love baby I got you bad camera
what's up who you are what's going down
dieter and I'm working in locations
today and uh watching really sketching
bloody Waller see stuff that's it's
disturbing why but fun and your store
than fun disturbingly fun yes it's
awesome
but my favorite part is that we're
having a cabbage or second milk and
we're all walked in the same room
afterwards big cabbage fest yes baby
let's see what we got there cabbage huh
is that what's going on here cabbage
pork and cabbage and tomatoes and
potatoes but it's good and hot warm
mm-hmm that's [ __ ] wicked Jamie's
here Kevin Smith
Waller's yes how was today today was
amazing day 13 with the hump day of our
final week here and good old Cramerton
North Carolina we shot we're on the
Enclave from now until the end of the
show it was amazing that Michael in the
pool with the with Justin in the suit
and he's leading him around the water
and got a lot of great underwater stuff
when the wall of Wallace is drowning and
season something else under the waters
coolest moments where I felt like jaws
you know not that it the whole movie
obviously I said at one point says I can
felt like we're making jaws for a minute
just a minute
because I'm not talented enough to make
two hours worth but one minute of Jaws
by now 20 years of filming I think I
could figure out one minute of Joseph
who did that today so it was kind of fun
and two more days and we go one more day
with our actors and we're done Michael
and Justin are done as of tomorrow and
that wrap and then Friday is all stunts
so the walrus fight begins tomorrow yeah
hey man Kevin Smith walrus yes day
fourteen one day left technically this
would have been the last day of the
movie it is our last day with actors
with Justin and Michael and then
tomorrow is all stunts we added a stunt
day to give ourselves some padding so we
can really get into that walrus fight so
today is all the close-ups of the boys
and their masks and clashing before we
get into the bodysuit stuff gonna be
pretty damn amazing almost done here in
North Carolina
crazy how fast it all went man Dave 14
feels like only you know one day ago
instead of 14 that I was a costed by a
camera at the moment I walked out of the
door first day heading to set and and
it's never ended thank god man you can
watch the progression of madness you
lasted longer than the rest that's
because you have gone full wars and
savagely beautiful on your porosity
you would kill me
[Music]
except y'all walls yes this is the end
of day 14 tomorrow's the last day today
was crazy it's long it's almost midnight
manatee it's been a long day of
craziness of bodies and tusks and
craziness
now as you can see because when some
people are leaving today is gonna be the
big clue and cast photos and that's
where you see the madness behind me
because people are like where do we go
where we're gonna do it where are we
taking the picture oh my goodness so
that's what we're gonna get and we're
gonna run over we can get it
walrus yes day 14 the end of the line
for mr. Justin Long we put in a Gretzky
like performance I told many times of
text I told other people on set it was
like watching Gretzky skate every time
you stepped on the ice you did something
amazing when they'd write about Gretzky
playing they would say as long as you
held up your end of the bargain magical
things would happen if you are on the
ice with them and you have absolutely
lived that man you are hands down to
Gretzky of actors do you every choice
was brilliant every you would go back to
the point reset and just do something
else funny on top of it something else
wonderfully dramatic give another shade
or another color it was like an honor of
how many years of love bordered watt
actors but this is hands-down the best
experience because Christ if every time
it was different organic to the flick
and better than you had done before
every time I was like great that's
[ __ ] perfect I get everything I need
to go one more take and he would crush
it so it was I don't know what to say
now I can't follow that up without
sounding like I'm just no but it's your
the best your best director I've worked
with man honest to god I'm we got along
well I'd say something funny and
sarcastic but I just I love you now yeah
and it wasn't funny or sarcastic I know
it's been like we had a really really
great time and the movies [ __ ] weird
and wonderful but he's been my co-pilot
for a long long time like there was a
script and we shot a better version of
that script and Kill Bill kid all that
stuff at making him like this kind of
hardened comic and stuff
got a chip on her shoulder that was all
stuff that Justin brought to it before
we even started shooting it was an honor
to watch you in the playground man you
and him to go together
you and Michael balance off each other
so nice the best job I've ever had
so thank you honest to god and hands
down best experience ever get your
makeup all right thanks thank you sir
thank you thank you thanks man
thank you guys hello JC Muse here Kevin
Smith mrs. Waller's yes
last day North Carolina day 15 I'm
excited the boy and lion
it's the last day he's excited we're all
excited man day 15 three weeks of
shooting three five-day weeks in a row
we still have three more days to shoot
in Los Angeles at some future date but
this is it for the majority of the MU
vets a 88 to 90 percent of the movie is
done at this point man it's been a hell
of a trip everyone worked on it we just
gave it their all and she had no
paycheck players or anything like that
it was pretty damn amazing and we have a
weird wonderful movie hands down it's
not finished but it feels like the best
movie ever made it's [ __ ] nuts
if film is supposed to transport you
somewhere to something in someplace
you've never seen before we really
accomplished that with this man they're
saying a couple kids in a convenience
store
crack and wise about [ __ ] Star Wars
this is this movie son movie you dive in
a tusk and you're taking on an adventure
in a gala and in an enclave far far away
walrus yes day 15
hey man Kevin for walrus guests over
here we got John say out of John hi John
is part of the blood and guts crew man
special effects makeup so over there
he's working on a blood gag it's gonna
happen under mr. parks while he's
getting gored by the walrus he'll show
you what it looks like right now
yeah we're just doing a test this is
going to be the goring of Mike Parks
we've got blood tubes separated the
proper distance to represent the tusks
on the mask pressurizing the bright pink
will go away
[Music]
[Music]
is accomplished
understood
[Music]
[Applause]
hey man Kevin Smith walrus yes the great
Michael parks with me
we just finished Michaels last shot of
the flick here in North Carolina as you
can see we put him through the ringer I
like to get blood for my actors blood
their whole reason we're here is because
I was like well I would love to if I had
to go back to a movie sex I didn't want
to do it no more I said I would love to
sit on a set what would make me go back
and it was the idea of watching Michael
parks act I loved it so much I'm red
state made every day fun do you know you
there's some people you could pretty
much understand where performance beats
are gonna come from you can kind of you
know predict it before they say it it's
not bad thing but when you meet an actor
see an actor who says things in ways
that you never imagined takes a sentence
and it plays it like a Stradivarius you
know it's that's somebody you want to
work with again and again so as i sat
there going okay man if I was to make
his walrus movie what would I like I
would like to see Michael parks sitting
there saying batshit crazy things and
shooing up the scenery and acting his
ass off and whatnot
so it was Michael was my muse the whole
time so every day we're here on set and
I see him in whatever location we were
shooting and I remember and I'm so
grateful the fact that we wouldn't make
this movie at all this movie wouldn't
exist if I didn't want to see him do
what he does so damn well I became a
director because I like acting I like
watching people act and stuff I'm a fan
for that kind of thing and watching him
act is just they up most the highest
point in terms of watching performance
man it's like watching porn for acting
you just can't believe where it's gone I
knew
by denies on that so having him wrapped
today and and wrapping with the death
scene being I'm so ironic and whatnot
you're finished in the movie and you're
finished in the movie on the movie is a
dream come true man we got to this place
he built this insanely wonderful
character that people will remember for
years to come
I put as per always I put something down
on the page and then he takes it and
flushes out turns it into something
beautiful all of his instincts were
always accurate all of the good was is
only the bad was mine
I don't believe any of it and I'm here
because of him is my favorite that's all
thank you Michael Walsh yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
they're Jews I read James thank you so
much it's a beautiful elegant
development that was supposed to be some
messy punk-rock kind of experiment
they'll make you think and you turned it
into the best film I've ever been
involved with
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Kevin Smith walrus yes behind me the
City of Charlotte on this hour rap night
we're done we've just finished the movie
man day 15 we finished on a shot of
walruses very poetic had a great shoot
everything went welcome in here come on
out here you come in come on good luck
America Mirror come in you come in come
in come in come in not awkward I'm so
awkward my own pod tusks here kids
couldn't have done it without this one
right here she's the first person that
read page isn't the first person that
was like keep going I want to see how it
ends and has been so supportive every
step of the way she just wanted to see
me go back to mega movies so she didn't
care what the movie was but she loved
tusks and she willed it to life as well
so it's kind of a big celebration for us
you could see the poster as you help cut
to a poster shot that she made for me
when we started and I know it's kind of
a cool thing to us for us to do his
first movie really like we've made lots
of movies together but does the first
one that we were kind of engaged
together throughout the entire process
it wasn't like I'm doing this come hell
or high water it was all predicated on
her support and her passion enthusiasm
so I don't know I'm hoping to get really
[ __ ] tonight because I'd done good
right up to that give it up I just want
some
ain't nobody got time for that nobody
got time for that
[Music]
I'm Lance anger McKee set production
assistant and I'm gonna do my best
walrus impression now that's about all I
got
hi I'm Barbara from crafty and my walrus
imitation would be who what's up this is
dieter with locations and this Mel
walrus impression my name is Curtis and
my imitation is Yong Kim are low I'm
Dave and this is my best walrus
imitation steve stephenson best boy grip
Oh Keith Sweeney craft service Tosk
can discuss tubes Oh what's your name
sir Jason Blackman so I'm Jason King I'm
the location manager and this is what a
walrus sounds like exactly like that
alright I am Heather Richardson I am the
hair department head and this is what a
walrus sounds like my name is Kai I'm
the base camp pa is my walls depression
hey kids
Marc McMahon's your video sis op ready
here we go
my name is Eric Carr and I'm with the
electric here on tusks and this is my
best walrus impression
Neil Graham the second second ad John
Chris firm production designer of walrus
walrus impressed
and that completely sucked ass cuz I'm
not an actor I just built the [ __ ]
Ritchie Hicks grip Department this is a
walrus
I'm James Laxton and I'm the cemetery
for this movie and walruses sound like
[Music]
I'm Kelly rhuebottom the prop master on
the best film of all time tusks and this
is my impression of Wallace Chris
alright I am Melissa I do props and this
is my walrus alright my name is Tim
McClellan um I'm a special effects
assistant and this is my version of a
walrus I guess hey my name is Monica
varios camera assistant second AC B
camera the best camera in the world and
it's my dress impression John with the
[ __ ] transpose named [ __ ]
mr. Kurtzman we do a walrus impression
for me
I'm doing the walrus impression get the
[ __ ] out of here